if you could have any superpower in the world
what would it be
invisibility
nice of you to join us Kayla
you're working with Lenore
oh hey girl
making yourself invisible isn't that hard
just when I thought you couldn't take up any more space
where did you get all of these
can you make me a dress I never made clothes for someone else before
I knew you'd say yes
would you have let me say no
oh my god
it looks good EWW
that's an empire waste universally flattering just like you
we're just getting started
The Fashion Institutes a new designer showcase you should enter
there is no way that I'm gonna get in
what do you want people to see when they look at your clothes
that they're capable of anything
I feel like a pageant dad ha ha
can make any outfit you want
but I don't deserve to wear them
why not
I want to be a great designer
and this competition can get me there
and I get to show my whole line
your whole line
it breaks my heart
to know that you can't give yourself what you've given everyone else
free clothes
confidence
if you could have it any superpower in the world
would it be